Hi everyone, I'm Fabio from Freewings and today we're going to tackle the meteo topic together.
It's mainly about exam preparation, or meteo basics in general.
There are basically two ways you can learn meteorology.
One is the minimum effort, just for the theory exam.
And of course there's a lot more weather knowledge
you can learn beyond that.
There are basically no limits.
There are five-volume tomes about meteorology.
This course is really geared toward the basics.
The course is also definitely useful for already-licensed pilots,
maybe to refresh weather knowledge,
or to learn some new things.
There's definitely interesting material in here for experienced pilots too.
But of course the course is mainly geared toward paraglider pilots,
so that you can hopefully apply this weather knowledge well.
Where the theory might be a bit dry
and a lot of things are hard to understand,
we'll dive right in.
Into this exciting field of weather knowledge.
One thing that's always close to my heart,
especially when it comes to meteorology,
is that there are two areas.
One is theoretical weather knowledge,
where you understand a lot of theory.
But the actual weather plays out in practice,
and that takes a lot of experience.
In flying practice, in meteo practice.
Lots of it ties into the actual flying.
The weather gets observed and analysed again and again,
and the theory is constantly cross-checked against practice.
That's also really important.
But in this section it's actually about theory
and about a basic understanding of weather.
First of all, the biggest question:
where does weather actually take place?
That's our atmosphere.
The atmosphere around the Earth is divided
into different layers.
The stratosphere, mesosphere, troposphere.
For us, the most relevant
is the troposphere,
where it meets the boundary
called the tropopause,
and in this layer
is where most of the humidity sits,
or most of the water vapour.
And that's where weather happens,
in the troposphere.
It's extremely thin,
if you look at it compared to the Earth,
almost like the layer of an onion.
(unclear)
Like the skin of an onion,
it's really a very, very thin region
where the weather happens
and where we of course also move around.
And as paraglider pilots,
we actually only move
in the very lowest layer
of this troposphere.
And what's important in theory,
for the theory exam,
is knowing
the composition
of the gases in this troposphere.
That is,
21% oxygen,
which is important for us
for breathing of course,
about 78% nitrogen,
and then there's about 1% noble gases,
for example argon,
but for us
for meteorology
that's not of great relevance,
the remaining noble gases
that are in there.
Now,
the troposphere
is not
the same thickness all around the globe,
it's a bit thinner
at the poles
than at the equator,
which has to do with the Earth's rotation.
At the equator it's roughly 18 kilometres,
and at the poles
it's about 8 kilometres.
For us in Europe,
by latitude,
where we mostly fly,
let's say
roughly 11 to 13 kilometres
thickness of this troposphere,
let's say 13,000 metres.
Now,
let's talk about the standard atmosphere.
This is always important,
in flight weather
and especially the theory exam
keeps asking
about the standard atmosphere.
That's the atmosphere
where weather
has completely balanced out,
we have no high-pressure areas,
no low-pressure areas,
and different factors
that influence us from outside.
We'll look at those.
When everything has balanced out,
we arrive at what's called the standard atmosphere.
It's basically a zero point,
where everything has equalised.
And there are a few numbers
and facts,
that the theory exam asks for.
The important one is the temperature gradient with altitude,
how the troposphere cools off.
We say 6.5 degrees
per 1000 metres of altitude,
or per 100 metres,
you can also say it as
0.65 degrees per 100 metres.
Then at the surface,
in the standard atmosphere,
we talk about 15 degrees,
and at the tropopause
about minus 56 degrees.
Especially those two numbers are important,
to learn for the theory exam.
The temperature gradient,
depending on the weather situation,
and the conditions,
as you'll learn later,
can of course vary.
But for the standard atmosphere we say 6.5 degrees
per 100 metres.
That's the temperature.
In the standard atmosphere we also talk about,
the standard pressure,
and the numbers
you'll hear again and again,
are 1013.25 hectopascals.
The air pressure,
when the whole troposphere
is in balance,
calculated at sea level,
the air pressure is always the same,
namely 1013.25 hectopascals.
And the troposphere height,
the highest,
where the tropopause begins,
is at 11 kilometres in the standard atmosphere.
Another important thing about air pressure,
how it decreases with altitude,
is not linear,
there's a rule of thumb.
We can say that
every 5500 metres of altitude
the air pressure halves.
So we can say,
at 5500 metres,
you'd have about 500,
or 506 hectopascals.
That's also a value,
the 5500 metres,
that's very important,
for the theory exam,
to learn.
So pressure of course decreases with altitude.
You can picture air pressure
as a column of air
above you,
all the way up to the tropopause.
And it's the same as water, for example,
those who dive will know:
the deeper you go in the water,
the higher the pressure,
the gravity of the Earth.
And so we can say,
the air pressure is of course
highest at the lowest point,
at sea level,
and decreases with altitude.
That has to do with gravity
and with this column of air
that presses down on us
and so to speak
generates air pressure.
Quick summary of the numbers:
1013.25, 15 degrees,
and 0.65 per 100 metres,
those are the numbers
that are relevant for us
for the standard atmosphere.
Right.
And if you think about it,
the standard atmosphere
is of course not always the same,
as we experience daily
with the weather.
There's a motor that drives this,
the sun that shines on the Earth,
and acts on it,
different land masses,
and more water,
different heating,
different seasons too,
with different sun angles depending on the season.
The sun isn't always at the same height.
Accordingly, all of this
throws the standard atmosphere
out of equilibrium,
and there are fluctuations,
in air pressure,
and that gives us our whole weather system.
And it's a really important motor
that
throws things out of balance,
and influences
different weather.
And we'll look at this together,
what kind of influence that has.
The sun,
that shines on the Earth,
warms
the ground,
that's important.
So the sun
doesn't actually warm air masses
as it shines through them,
it might warm them slightly,
or it can't really warm them,
it actually only warms
the ground-level air layers.
That's the air layer
that's really sitting on the ground,
with the radiation heat
that arises there,
and the ground-level air layer warms up.
And the heating
of these ground-level air layers
varies by region around the world,
distributed across the globe,
where things warm differently.
Regions at the equator
warm up more, of course,
than a region
in the polar areas.
An air mass
is actually a volume of air
that has the same properties.
For example warmer air masses,
and colder ones.
And these are always regions
that, over several hundred kilometres,
have the same properties,
so the same air pressure,
or the same temperature,
or similar temperatures,
warmer temperatures
or colder temperatures.
Basically, it works like this:
over regions
that are colder for longer
than the surroundings,
higher air pressure forms.
And over regions
that are warm for longer,
you get
the formation of
lower pressure.
And accordingly,
in the tropical regions,
for example, we get tropical low-pressure areas,
and in the polar regions
we get the polar high-pressure areas.
That's how different air pressures form.
And then the pressure areas develop
that we'll dive into in the next few slides.
So,
that was about
what kind of influence
this has on our weather.
You can picture it
as belts
around the world.
Around the globe,
there are the so-called Hadley cells,
they are the low-pressure
and high-pressure rings.
There are more of them
than what's on this graphic.
Basically though,
in the tropical regions
you get a low-pressure belt
and in the polar regions
a high-pressure belt.
And so we also have tropical air masses
and polar air masses.
And here too we'll now
in the next few minutes learn
what kind of influence that has on our weather.
So look here,
there's different heating
of different regions.
Accordingly we have high-pressure areas
and low-pressure areas.
And we can see here in the middle, for example,
the number,
that we can recognise,
from the standard atmosphere.
The 1013.25, and as soon as
the air pressure drops below this.
Below that,
we talk about a low-pressure area.
Here in Europe,
very pronounced examples
of low-pressure areas,
we talk about 955 hectopascals,
and very pronounced
high-pressure areas,
we talk about 1035 hectopascals.
Right now it's the time
of global warming.
Unfortunately, the values
are getting more extreme.
There are even high-pressure areas
that reach up to 1048 hectopascals.
So those are very strong
pressure differences.
Accordingly,
the
meteorological phenomena get stronger.
And the stronger weather,
that we unfortunately keep experiencing,
with the storms, for example,
has exactly to do with these pressure fluctuations,
and we'll get to it later too,
in a high-pressure area
air masses sink,
and in a low-pressure area
air masses rise.
That's very important later
for flying weather,
which we'll get to.
And basically,
like every gas
or every liquid,
air masses have
the need to equalise pressure.
That means
air masses will always
flow from high pressure to low pressure,
because pressure wants to equalise.
And accordingly,
especially for us when waiting,
or in the lower air layers,
the air flow is important,
that air flows from high
to low, and accordingly
wind develops,
the wind systems
that you can feel,
when the wind blows.
And so we get
the high-altitude flow,
which is important for us
to recognise wind directions
and read them from the charts.
Then we come to isobar charts
wait,
you might have heard of those
or read about them in the theory book.
There are weather charts
where exactly the weather phenomena
that we just
discussed
are described.
Weather charts,
they're created
partly from current measurements,
where you measure with barometers
or air pressure.
And of course the computer models,
that based on the measurements
try to predict
the weather,
and
compute it in advance.
And then come
the funny-looking weather charts,
which we'll now look at more closely,
how to read them.
Isobar charts,
isobars,
those are the lines
you see there,
isobars,
described,
are the regions
that have the same air pressure,
or the same air pressure,
simply put,
where it prevails.
So for example,
1025 hectopascals,
you can't see it well here,
in the next chart
you can see it better.
And everywhere
the lines run,
calculated at sea level,
that's very important,
the pressure is calculated
at sea level,
where the same air pressure prevails.
That's where the name isobar chart comes from.
Iso means the same,
bar
is pressure,
everywhere
where the same air pressure prevails,
such a line gets drawn.
And on such an isobar chart
fronts are often drawn in,
naturally,
we'll come back to that later
in the course,
what these fronts
are about.
Here you see a larger isobar chart,
and you see again the high-pressure areas,
the low-pressure areas,
and there are reasons
why different air pressures form,
to keep in mind,
and the season for example.
This is a slightly larger view
of an isobar chart.
Their appearance
varies a bit,
depending on the newspaper,
or by which meteo service,
looks a bit different,
but fundamentally they all have
the same elements in them.
Those are the high-pressure areas,
isobars,
and the coloured lines,
the fronts.
Right.
So here's what it looks like,
we've just simply shown
on our globe,
the different pressure areas
that form,
over different land masses and seas.
They have different pressures,
and different pressure values.
And the Coriolis force,
that's a physical phenomenon,
Earth's rotation,
deflects different
air masses,
that get moving,
differently,
and these create
circular motions,
so rotating movements,
to put it visually,
like a drain for example,
different forces arise,
or the shape of a drain,
creates a vortex,
when water flows down a drain
and starts to rotate,
and that creates a rotating motion.
In air masses, the Coriolis force is mainly
the deciding factor,
that air masses
also start to rotate.
Accordingly in the north,
of our globe,
so everything north
of the equator,
it works like this:
in a high-pressure area
the air masses rotate clockwise,
and in a low-pressure area
counter-clockwise.
I've built myself a little memory aid here:
for me a high-pressure area
is something positive,
because the sun shines on us
and we have nice weather, flying weather.
So it's positive,
and for me that means clockwise,
in a low-pressure area
counter-clockwise.
The rotation.
In the southern hemisphere
it's the opposite,
for example in Australia,
the whole thing works exactly
opposite,
just for those
who go on flying trips
and fly in South America
or Australia
it's reversed.
Quite nicely,
in a low-pressure area
is of course also naturally
the case with a hurricane.
There you can really see
how the air mass rotates.
A hurricane
is nothing other
than an extreme low-pressure area.
Accordingly you can see,
this is a hurricane,
it's in the northern
hemisphere,
you can see again
counter-clockwise,
rotating in the low-pressure area
in such a way.
The air masses.
You can see very nicely
on the cloud bands
of the hurricane.
Accordingly,
on this slide,
you can see
that the air masses
equalise the low pressure,
they flow from high pressure
into the low-pressure area.
But they don't flow
in a direct line
from high to low,
but in a curve into the low-pressure area.
About wind direction.
Reading it
we'll look at on the charts.
We'll look at that
in a few slides,
how to read wind direction
on the isobar charts.
We can also read wind speed
from
these isobar charts
by
to put it visually
comparing isobar charts.
I can also always
read them a bit like topographic maps.
So there are different elevation lines,
different pressure lines
and accordingly
I have for example
a high-pressure area
of varying heights.
A high pressure
and its influence accordingly
is of varying strength,
you can think of it as a 4000-metre peak
of high pressure.
That's extremely strong.
There are very many isobar lines,
very many topographic lines
from the landscape.
Or it can also be just a hill.
But the high
actually only describes the highest pressure,
so the highest elevation
of the landscape
or of the hill.
And accordingly
it can be higher
or less high.
And accordingly
the weather influences,
that we'll discuss in a bit,
are stronger or weaker.
Let's talk about,
let's now quickly look at,
how from an isobar chart
you can read off wind direction.
Basically we have,
here's an infographic
from the theory exam.
We've now seen different pressure areas
before.
The exam doesn't make it
that simple,
where an H and a T
are put in.
And then we know
what the pressure area is.
Accordingly they want
us,
to read the pressure
from the isobars
and we see for example,
at the edge in Navier above,
you see 900,
it's relatively hard to read.
980 hectopascals for example,
you know
that's below 1013.25.
So it must be low pressure.
Accordingly you can
in your mind
write the T
where it would be,
in there.
Accordingly we know
that the air masses
in the low-pressure area
rotate counter-clockwise.
Rotating.
And then you can
along the isobar lines,
that you see,
you can,
if you want,
draw little arrows,
or you can of course
just visualise it,
you can imagine
many arrows along the isobar lines,
depicted,
and there it is,
if you imagine,
and accordingly
you read off the wind direction.
So here for example
in England
you'd always have a westerly flow.
And in the high-pressure area,
at 1030 hecto-
pascals,
we have the highest elevation.
That's the high,
it rotates
clockwise.
Accordingly
the wind goes
along the isobars.
And then we can really
for the theory exam,
say that the wind is always
parallel to the isobars
and gets read off.
So we really take
the line
as the wind direction.
Because the wind
is a circulating
motion that equalises
out,
the pressure.
Right.
So that's for wind direction
and wind direction.
I could also
ask,
for example,
as the high and low-pressure area,
as a connected system function.
Yes, we can
imagine,
like two gears,
that mesh with each other
and accordingly
the wind
it has to also
ask better,
maybe.
Right.
When reading wind,
we'll now look
at the next few slides.
One thing
that's of
great importance for wind
is,
wind direction.
We need to know,
because we need to know wind direction
for example,
for which launch site to use.
Wind direction is also
important for different weather phenomena.
You can
imagine,
pull out a compass.
With north at 0 degrees,
east at 90 degrees,
south at 180 degrees,
west at 270 degrees.
Accordingly
wind direction
is sometimes also
given
in 360 degrees.
Wind direction is always described
by where the wind is coming from.
So if the wind
comes from the south,
then we talk about south wind,
north wind
and west wind,
accordingly with
ground air mass
from the west
and accordingly
is west wind.
And accordingly
we also give as,
so when you have wind
from 90 degrees
is a bit the
common unit
for wind speed.
We can roughly,
in most
weather stations for example
the wind is given that way.
And here
another natural
second example,
20 degrees.
Times 2,
40,
minus 6,
that's 4,
so it gives
360-degree
wind.
Converting it
is important,
so we're fluent
and prepared
for the theory exam.
Then if you also
look at the wind topic
one more,
the wind gradient.
If you imagine
now,
that my circulating
wind system comes,
with a westerly wind,
and it glides
over the Earth's
surface.
Accordingly the wind
wind at altitude
is mostly stronger.
At ground level
the wind has friction.
Accordingly it gets
slower,
but it also becomes
a bit turbulent.
So accordingly
there are
some ground rules,
that in the thin layer
the ground-level layer
the wind is weaker,
but turbulent.
And in higher air layers
it's stronger,
but laminar.
Logically there are
still different
meteorological phenomena,
where, yes,
maybe sometimes
a bit turbulent
in the air mass
at higher altitudes,
or the whole thing also
acts a bit oddly.
But as a basic principle
it goes like this,
if you know the wind flow,
at the ground it's
weaker and turbulent.
Right.
The wind gradient.
By the way, a gradient
is always a progression,
in this sense
with altitude.
So temperature gradient
later in the theory course,
it's always about
a progression
with altitude.
When we talk about a gradient,
in general,
but in meteorology
it's mainly about altitude.
Right.
On the topic of wind, there's
another topic that belongs with it,
that for us paraglider pilots
is especially important
and that's turbulence.
If you want
the most peaceful flight possible,
the perspective,
when you're in turbulence,
you'd want to know,
and know why
this turbulence forms.
And how to
deal with it,
maybe see it a bit beforehand
and the areas
that you fly into
and maybe don't.
And here it's
going back
to types of
turbulence,
that we distinguish,
and which are also tested in the theory exam,
asked about.
First there's
the best turbulence,
actually,
definitely pleasant,
but maybe also less pleasant,
thermic turbulence.
That's probably the one
we're most exposed to
are,
when flying,
because the thermals we fly,
that we move accordingly,
are always in thermic
air masses.
And those
who have felt it already,
know,
use them well.
And so it's about,
when an air mass rises,
the air mass is
basically
relatively calm,
it sits there
and then the thermic
bubble rises up,
which we'll later
go into in detail
and in this rising zone
there are also often
next to it,
a neighbouring downdraft zone
next to thermic updrafts.
Accordingly
you get there
wind shear
in the vertical
and in this wind shear
you of course feel
the turbulence.
Accordingly
thermic turbulence.
Then there's
wind shear
in this sense.
That's something,
it's about,
when you have two different
wind directions,
when you have a westerly down low
and easterly up high,
or usually the reverse,
or you have
a Bise in there,
so easterly wind,
and westerly up high,
then there's, in the middle,
a mixing layer,
where the two wind systems
meet
and accordingly
you get exactly
at this altitude line,
where the winds meet,
so-called shear wind,
and then it brings
with it the turbulence,
or rather
into the turbulence,
the turbulence,
due to wind strength.
For us as
pilots
this isn't that relevant,
often,
but it's a phenomenon,
that there's such a layer,
where things get bumpy,
that often has to do with mountain wind,
for example,
which we'll also
come to later.
With mechanical
turbulence,
that's the third
category,
it's about exactly,
when an air mass
flows over an object,
for example a forest,
or a house,
or anything,
or even
most importantly for us
of relevance,
a mountain,
a ridge for example,
when you have strong wind
and it flows over the object.
Many know
this from all
those flow videos,
for them,
we have a car in a wind tunnel,
afterwards there are
behind the object
vortices,
which can be unpleasant
could be,
of course depending on wind speed,
they could be unpleasant
be,
or even dangerous,
if the wind is
weak though,
then the amounts
are completely negligible.
On the landing site
it's of course
important,
if you
land behind the house,
when you have strong wind,
is of course
not so advantageous.
Maybe a couple more words,
that come up again and again,
when flying,
is windward and lee.
The topic,
that we're on right now,
is,
the lee side
always describes the wind-
away side.
And the windward side
is the wind-facing side.
Now it's always asked,
from where do we look at it,
do we look,
do we look from an object.
Or,
we can also,
we can,
for example at the launch site
talk about the mountain ridge.
Then we have the lee side,
and that's simply seen from the mountain,
the wind-away side.
So,
back side
of the mountain,
when the air mass
hits that side.
Or,
in this sense,
maybe a house,
a lee side of the house,
and a windward side of the house.
On landing it's
exactly the same.
We can
though, build up windward layers,
build up,
seen from the landing site,
on the windward side,
facing the wind.
Right.
About windward and lee,
in particular keeps coming up
during the course
of your training
and in the theory exam.
Then we can
to the last
weather phenomenon,
which is about wind,
which is also very,
very important for us,
for paraglider pilots.
And it's
about
us understanding
the Venturi effect,
the so-called Venturi effect,
you might already
from aerodynamic theory
be familiar with this,
the so-called concept.
With the Venturi effect
in there
it's about,
whenever
a wind flow
or air masses
are forced
to,
narrow.
So as a
first example,
for example a valley,
if there's a broad valley,
that suddenly narrows.
And the wind,
that flows through,
becomes a valley wind,
for example,
the Gitz,
in the narrowing
of the valley,
a wind acceleration.
So we have
significantly stronger wind,
than
in the wide part
of the valley.
Accordingly,
when you of course
fly,
when you expect a lot of wind,
that you in an
open valley exit
also in a narrow
slot,
for example.
That's the Venturi effect.
The same Venturi effect,
you also get
on a mountain
or on a hill.
When my air mass comes,
you can imagine,
in nice parallel lines,
where the wind comes from.
And then,
we have a hill,
where the air mass
is forced to rise
and accordingly
to a narrowing
on the hill
or on the mountain
is forced.
And accordingly
the wind speed
on the mountain
at the top is the strongest.
So,
when we once on the mountain
stand
and want to launch
on the hill,
and there's
very strong wind,
afterwards a descent,
if of course
with the paraglider
a few hundred metres
and then we notice,
that in the lower layer
most of the wind
is much, much weaker,
than really
at the very top,
full compression in there.
Is of course something,
that you
maybe with soaring
in flying practice
or in real flight have already done.
Of course important
is,
when we stay in exactly the area
stay,
where there's lift,
where the wind is rising.
But really important,
at the top on the ridges
for the most part
an acceleration
of the wind.
Acting,
when the Venturi effect
right.
Now we have wind,
we have it,
we have also learned,
low-pressure area,
high-pressure area,
if you learn
from the isobars
to read wind,
wind strength,
maybe also read,
because the closer,
the isobars
are together,
the stronger the wind.
And the wider
and farther,
the isobars are,
think,
of a topographic map,
a landscape map,
the wider apart,
the isobars are,
the weaker
the pressure gradient,
the,
weaker,
is also the equalisation flow
between the pressure areas.
It's really important,
that we put it together,
the different topic areas,
that we're now looking at,
and the more,
the understanding becomes,
of what's happening with the air masses,
happens,
the more you can also
put together,
and it's like a puzzle,
the pieces fit together interestingly,
and then flying weather
really becomes an interesting field,
and we really enjoy it,
when you understand the connections too
and really understand the basics.
And that's why this course is so important,
that you really understand the basics,
and don't just learn it by rote.
And we'll continue with this,
in the next slide.
The next topic,
that we'll go into,
is actually the only thing,
that we haven't explained on this isobar chart.
On the isobar chart.
What we haven't covered yet,
are the fronts.
Those are the coloured lines,
the blue, red, and violet lines
with various symbols on them.
And they lead to very specific
meteorological conditions,
which for us as paraglider pilots
are very, very important,
that we understand,
and the dangers
of the fronts we know,
but to understand fronts,
let's go back,
to how a front even forms,
like a stationary front.
And we have to come back to it.
The air mass,
on the globe,
heats up differently,
with the colder air mass
in the polar regions,
and with the warmer, moister air mass
in the tropical regions,
or subtropical regions.
And as I mentioned before,
an air mass describes,
a region,
an air,
a volume,
that has the same properties.
Here we have two different air masses.
And in between
there's an air mass boundary.
And this air mass boundary
is described,
by a front.
We have the blue triangles,
that describes a cold front,
and with the red dots,
so the round ones,
graphics,
that describes a warm front.
And then there's also a mixed-
form, an occlusion,
which we'll later
come to,
that's the third form of a front.
Now we can imagine,
we have the various air masses,
and now we have for example
a low-pressure area,
where there are vortices.
Think of it,
maybe an extremely strong hurricane.
There's a huge vortex,
it's like a mixer,
that starts mixing
the air mass.
And accordingly
fronts begin to form.
A cold air mass pulls,
from north toward the south.
And when an air mass pulls,
from south toward the north.
And accordingly a frontal system
starts to move.
An air mass gets moved,
and accordingly is pushed out.
And so
step by step the fronts form.
So you'll notice here,
my arrows in the direction,
for the low-pressure area,
that rotates,
that the whole thing pulls
into rotation
and accordingly forms the fronts.
And here you can
see quite nicely,
that first a warm front gets produced,
the red line,
and at minimum a cold front,
that follows behind.
Now you see,
as one will explain shortly,
is faster on the move,
than a warm front.
So, a cold front
is almost double,
as fast in its movement as a warm front.
And accordingly,
comes the,
that the cold front,
the warm front,
eventually catches up,
and you see it in the centre,
of the low-pressure,
forms,
what we call occlusion,
a mixed form of the two fronts.
We'll now go into detail,
into this,
what that means,
or what that looks like.
We can see here,
how the air masses simply rotate,
how the various front systems form,
the two air masses.
Now we see,
maybe a strong cold front there.
That's almost the most important front,
or the most dangerous front for paraglider pilots.
Here comes a cold front.
You can imagine,
it pulls from left to right in the graphic,
the cold air mass
pushes itself underneath.
It's heavier.
Accordingly it pushes itself
underneath,
in a wedge-like form.
We can see the shape
of the line in the weather chart,
is such a wedge form,
where it comes from.
Accordingly cold air
pushes underneath,
the warm air,
which is lighter,
and accordingly it gets pushed up.
Accordingly there's large-scale lift,
large-scale lift,
across this distance.
and it can always bring thunderstorms with it.
And now you see the thunderstorms,
also of course very strong wind, very strong gusts.
That's of course extremely dangerous for paragliding.
What's of course the problem with cold fronts,
ahead of a cold front,
we usually have nice weather.
It's such a phase, it's nice weather.
Makes you want to fly, maybe there's also a bit of wind.
In Switzerland it's often accompanied by westerly winds,
or also a bit of Foehn, we'll come to that later.
But they're usually accompanied by a bit of wind,
but often there are good flying conditions ahead of the front,
because the air mass becomes unstable.
It rises, and that's where you want to be.
Now if you've seen on this weather chart, on this isobar chart,
which hopefully before a flight you always briefly study,
that a cold front is approaching,
then be really cautious about flying right then.
Because with it comes a lot of wind
and with it a lot of rising air masses,
where you really can't land quickly.
And I think the cold front is really brutal,
and for conservative pilots especially,
if there's a cold front on the day, you can leave it alone.
Cold fronts come at 40 to 60 km/h.
It can be relatively fast, very important.
The wind can of course get much stronger, the thunderstorm corners.
And it takes about six to twelve hours to cross Switzerland.
So it can happen relatively quickly, right.
So be careful with cold fronts.
Really important is, if before a flight
you should always check the weather radar
and especially keep your eyes on the sky.
Because there you can see thunderstorms coming,
looks roughly like this.
We'll cover the thunderstorm topic in more detail in the course.
But for all those on foot, when thunderstorms come in a line,
when you see on the weather radar what it looks like now,
then it's always extremely dangerous.
Because it's a very active front, the thunderstorms are very strong.
And I can imagine it a bit like a line.
And if you've seen such a thunderstorm line on the weather radar,
then I personally would land very quickly.
Even when the thunderstorms are still 100 km away,
because they can cause very strong winds.
And then there can be cold air gust fronts from thunderstorms,
which are very, very dangerous for paraglider pilots.
We'll get into the thunderstorm area of the theory course
in a bit more detail later.
But here about the weather radar.
Important about the weather radar, one more practical tip,
don't just look at the radar,
but at the natural sky,
because the radar images,
they're usually 40 minutes old,
or half an hour even after the fact.
There are also current ones,
but observe the natural sky,
and don't just look at your phone,
if you fly enough.
Right.
Then a small addition about thunderstorms.
The closer to the centre,
of a low-pressure area for example,
that you move into this front,
the more active a cold front is.
If you only graze the very outermost tip
of this front,
like in the case here in Greece,
it can be, that the whole weather phenomenon
is just a bit of rain
and not so terrible,
for flying maybe,
but be careful,
we have a lot to do with showers.
But if you're really right in the middle
of the cold front,
afterwards it's really very active
and afterwards it's definitely nothing for flying.
But if you only get grazed,
you can in some circumstances still fly,
and it leads to a slight destabilisation
of the air masses.
But here, rather for advanced pilots,
but good to know with this gradation,
that a front in the centre is always stronger,
than in the outermost area of this front.
Then we can move on to the second frontal phenomenon
and that's the warm front.
The warm front is like this,
that a warmer air mass
always leads in front,
rides up onto a colder air mass.
With air masses it's always about,
which one is colder or warmer.
It doesn't have to mean,
that one is warm,
you can have an air mass,
where it's minus 20 degrees and the other air mass
is minus 10 degrees,
is also cold,
but it's colder,
than the other air mass.
Or warmer.
So a warmer air mass comes.
Accordingly the air mass
is less dense,
a bit lighter
and it glides up onto the cold air mass.
And accordingly a warm front comes
in such a wedge shape.
Here we can mark it,
the diagonal lines,
the air masses,
that ride up,
form a diagonal line.
And it makes for us,
as paraglider pilots,
actually much less danger,
than a cold front,
in this drop shape.
And we can imagine.
If I'm down there on the mountain,
and we fly,
then I see very much,
early before the warm front,
over the ground sky,
I see high cloud layers,
coming.
The sky gets more and more milky.
It's not really nice,
for flying.
And the air mass comes in slowly.
And the indication,
if it won't fly well,
it's not so good.
We see then,
the warm front,
much less dangerous,
than a cold front.
But logically,
I wouldn't fly into a warm front
either,
it's also always associated with wind.
If you also see,
a warm front,
it comes much more slowly,
so it comes at 15 to 25 km/h,
it needs 12 to 24 hours,
or even more,
to cross Switzerland,
so it's usually a slightly longer process.
When that means two days
of no flying weather,
and that brings ahead of it
as discussed,
high shading,
which weakens thermal activity,
weakens
and brings really good flying weather.
Within a warm front
the only problem is,
that there is,
also for mountaineers for example,
is,
that when I'm down there,
I can't see,
through the cloud cover,
and see,
what's there,
because within a warm front
it can in some
and certain circumstances form thunderstorms.
So especially,
within the occlusion,
where they come together,
it can in some
circumstances build into huge thunderstorm towers,
which are of course very dangerous,
and bring very strong weather with them,
hail,
and you can't see at all,
because the cloud layers cover it.
I find,
above us the cloud names,
that come with the warm front,
come,
we'll just learn,
the cloud names,
we'll look at one more.
But,
I think it's good to know,
the warm front
comes usually with stratus-like
clouds, so with cirrostratus,
altostratus,
nimbostratus,
it's always associated with stratus.
Because stratus means,
and why those are cloud names,
and how they look,
we'll go into
in another chapter,
when we look at cloud names.
But just remember,
also cirrostratus,
altostratus,
nimbostratus,
is also tested in the theory exam
very likely,
when the clouds drive,
then you can basically
already keep the warm
in the back of your mind.
Right.
Here an image,
of how it comes,
the clouds look like this.
Those are stratus clouds.
Those are always quite closed
cloud cover,
that always sinks lower,
as time passes
as the front approaches.
And the cloud forms look roughly like this.
Then we can
move to the chapter on occlusion.
Occlusion,
you don't actually need a lot of knowledge
the theory exam asks about it but
nonetheless tests it.
It's a mixed form,
of the two fronts.
And as said,
for us now
in practice especially relevant.
Is that an occlusion,
often the sky is covered
and so-called,
thunderstorms occur.
Those are thunderstorm towers,
that are inside,
because the cold front
and the warm front catch up,
it's faster.
Can there back thunderstorms occur,
if we're up front,
you see,
the thunderstorm towers not at all.
And it's really important for us,
and we know,
that this can happen.
So very detailed question,
that doesn't have extremely much
to do with flying practice
or for most paraglider pilots
isn't of great relevance,
there are two characters of occlusions
and that gets tested in the exam.
(unclear)
There's a so-called occlusion
with cold-front character
and occlusion with warm-front character.
Accordingly on such an occlusion image
seen with the two drawn lines
one of these air masses
was simply,
(unclear)
Accordingly
lines with cold-front character
(unclear)
(unclear) — questions and
and the elements that are different here, for normal pilots.
Right.
Let's wrap up the recording briefly.
A few tips.
Here are the two charts, the basics,
that come up most often.
Important on the left-hand chart,
summarised.
To recap.
We have different pressure areas.
Think, where's the low pressure?
Where's the high pressure?
How does it rotate?
Accordingly the air masses.
High pressure clockwise.
Low pressure counter-clockwise.
There we have the wind direction.
Wind direction.
Picture pulling out a compass.
From which direction does the wind come.
Accordingly give it.
When the isobars are close together,
we have very strong winds.
When they're far apart,
then we have relatively weak winds.
What does far mean?
And as a Swiss reference example,
if the isobars,
if we take the size of Switzerland,
are close together,
the Swiss hectopascal gradient is important.
Then we have relatively strong wind.
Once the isobars are far apart,
say twice over Switzerland and so wide,
as Switzerland, then it's really weak wind.
Accordingly we have here in the Mediterranean area
very weak wind.
And then of course in the centre
of the high pressure, relatively weak wind.
So, reading off wind direction and wind strength.
Then we get asked about the chart as well.
Then we have here the two charts,
where we additionally see the fronts.
And for that, we need to know mainly,
what kinds of cloud forms come with the fronts.
We have for sure thunderstorms in the cold front.
We have maybe a bit of cumulus cloud formation.
And...
Sorry, just a moment.
We have here a cold front.
The triangles are very important.
The shapes of the graphics are important.
So, when there are triangular cold fronts,
thunderstorms are definitely a topic.
We have here a warm front,
symbolised by the run with the round symbols.
Accordingly we have the,
the cloud cover,
as we discussed.
The low pressure is in the low pressure,
with the already drawn lines,
no joke.
There's for sure a storm, since it's raining.
And for example a Dane,
always a high-pressure approach,
it's a multiple-choice learner,
and also tap.
And I always remind you of the basic rules,
that we covered with the two charts.
Right.
Then you're well prepared.
For exam questions about isobar charts and the run-up.
Then we can move to a huge topic,
which is important,
in the theory exam moved on.
If you really want to paraglide well,
if you want to go cross-country,
then it's the thermal.
I'd suggest,
that I take a quick break with something to drink,
as the throat dries out,
the course isn't quite over yet,
still quite a lot to discuss.
Then I'll take a quick break now,
for the next chapter lies ahead.